I'm Greg Jennings and this is build your
squad I'm here right now with be our
gridiron to build my all-time squad okay
I am going to start with my quarterback
and this for me is rather easy and I'm
going to tell you why I'm going with Tom
Brady he's the most clutch quarterback
I've seen in action close-up on
television he has the most Super Bowl so
if I'm looking for somebody to win me a
game I'm going with that guy that's my
guy
I don't care what you say that's my guy
next running back now you're gonna be a
little disappointed possibly maybe not I
really don't care we got the great water
Payton I love water Payton I would put
him there but then we got Jim Brown and
we got on but I grew up in Michigan here
me I grew up in Michigan so I watched
this guy my entire life special said you
know what I'm so special I'm done I
don't want to play no more
I'm time too good for this league that's
not what he said but that's kind of what
I felt like because he was the only
bright spot on the Detroit Lions and
seemed to be the only spot bright spot
that ever existed on the Detroit Lions
so Barry Sanders it doesn't matter what
you think that's my paper I'm going to
skip this row for now and come back
later I'm going to go to my defensive
backs and it's Brett is rather easy I
mean fine
do I have to explain why I mean just be
the ultimate prime-time playmaker I mean
I get punt return covered I got I got
all secondary levels covered because
he's done it all I can isolate them one
on one I can do whatever I need to do we
got it he we good and we the fastest man
on the field so I mean need i say more
I'm gonna go here to to my defensive end
slash linebacker this is tough this is
really tough because I played against
this guy great I played against this guy
Derrick Brooks I didn't play against
Bruce Smith although I recognize the
greatness I did not play against the
great Reggie White although I respect
and realize how great he was
but Tecmo Bowl told me that Lawrence
Taylor was that dude then and I feel
like if he played right now he would
still be that dude just special I mean
he was the only player on Tecmo Bowl
that can actually catch bo Jackson
like you can't catch bo Jackson like
whoa what is that
guess Lawrence Taylor man he created and
passed away for guys like Ray Lewis
that's mom that's why I gotta put
Lawrence Taylor there and for receiver
now I know the the pic naturally
everyone would say Baldwin Jerry Rice my
favorite player probably all time
however
who can make a play I can and he can
I'm not picking him right now but that
man right there he just was special
Randy Moss man I mean it's like and I
know you're gonna say our man he was
only a deep threat he couldn't go across
the middle don't care I don't need the
whole costume to do what you do that's
why he up here that's why his face is
here and I mean mine should have been
but I told him don't put it up there cuz
I don't want to
that's biased I didn't want to be that
and now I'm a lot in my pics this is my
squad I don't care what you think if you
say Greg nah man what you are you
kidding me I'm gonna say so yeah I guess
I am kidding you if you say Greg that's
amazing now I would have had the same
five I hope that's why I put them up
there but these are my five that's who
I'm going into any game with and I'm
winning and we don't get a bunch of
these a bunch of them